so in this video we're going to talk
about the aging face okay is there any
solution can you actually slow down this
process unfortunately it's inevitable
everyone is going to age but if there's
something we can do to slow it down that
would be a very good thing
some people have accelerated aging other
people don't a lot has to do with your
environment which I'm going to touch on
as well is the strength of your ability
to recover and repair there are certain
nutrients that are really necessary in
the repair of your DNA and that relates
to how fast you age but typically what
happens as we age we start getting these
horizontal and vertical lines or
wrinkles on the forehead in between the
eyes you'll notice that the skin
especially on top of the eyelid starts
becoming very very thin almost paper
thin you can see it on the cheeks as
well there's loss of collagen there's a
loss of elasticity the ligaments that
support the skin to the face are
atrophying they're shrinking the fat on
the face starts to atrophy and you start
losing that and starts to sag underneath
the eye lids right here you may also notice
a dark circle underneath the eye as well
and the tissue on top of the eye and the
eyelid starts drooping you may also
notice that the fat layer underneath the
cheek bones becomes atrophied then you
start sagging tissue and so you lose
your cheek bones so you have the sagging
eyebrows and the lids dark circles even
bone loss around the face around the jaw
and the teeth you potentially could also
lose the fullness around the lips and
there's also a very thin kind of like a
sheath muscle called the platysma
underneath your your neck that becomes
atrophied and you get that turkey
gobbler appearance I think I'm actually
starting to get that myself but other
than the wrinkles the sagging skin the
dark circles and that little turkey
gobbler appearance you're doing
fantastic alright so let's just kind of
forget about that for a second and talk
about what can we do to slow this thing
down okay well there's really two things
happening you have the breakdown of
tissue and then
have the building up of tissue okay I'm
talking about proteins at the cellular
level so you have the oxidation or the
damaging of proteins that can definitely
come from smoking smokers tend to age
prematurely and then there is people who
get excessive amounts of Sun including
sunburns Sun Sun is good too much Sun
could age the skin then you have the
chemicals that are put on the skin as
well as in your foods and I know a lot
of women put up just layers of makeup on
the skin on a daily basis and then you
take it off you just want to make sure
that those chemicals are non-toxic then
you have alcohol that will age the skin
in certain medications and recreational
drug and then you have sugar and junk
foods and refined carbohydrates those
will definitely age your skin probably
more than anything and then you have
stress okay on the flip side what do we
do to counter that this is what you
should focus on regular exercise okay
regular exercise that will counter this
regular exercise will provide a lot of
oxygen to the lungs to the tissues it
will slow down the aging process
especially on your face because it's
going to drive blood flow into the
tissues fasting very very powerful I've
done other videos on this in fact I'm
going to put a link down below but
fasting will do two things it'll
increase your antioxidant Network to
counter some of this stuff right here
it'll also kick in and turn on certain
genetic factors that help something
called autophagy recycling old damaged
tissue especially protein and giving you
new tissue it'll increase stem cells
especially if you do periodic prolonged
fasting
to actually help your body replenish old
cells so you have less wrinkles also
fasting helps your blood sugars and
right there that's going to actually
reduce oxidation now consuming
antioxidant foods are a must and that
would be these things called vegetables
especially cruciferous vegetables now
there's other antioxidants and other
foods too like seafood and grass-fed
meat and eggs as well but here's the
thing when you talk about DNA repair and
the
nutrients required for DNA repair these
are the key nutrients that are essential
and I put some of the research down
below vitamin b3 okay
now the way that you become deficient is
by drinking a lot of alcohol or sugar or
or also consuming a lot of corn will
cause a deficiency of b3 do you realize
that the consumption of corn from the
70s to now has increased by 3x that's
crazy so we need b3 for DNA repair also
magnesium very necessary for DNA repair
you can get magnesium from a lot of
vegetables leafy greens things like that
zinc very necessary for DNA repair
shellfish seafood sea kelp
oysters folate very important to
prevent DNA damage and protect the DNA
and this word folate comes from another
word foliage which is vegetable so you
get folate from vegetables and then
DHA which is an omega-3 fatty acid it's
in salmon sardines cod liver oil and
then you have vitamin C always make sure
that you get it from a natural source
vegetables would be a good source all
right it's very simple focus on
increasing these and decreasing these if
you haven't seen my other videos on
Aging check them out I put them right
here